what strikes me at the airport a lot
guys is that it seems like
who flies in here a lot
you just one quiet me
are you sitting under the chair holy
[ __ ]
that sounded like your last breath
who said that
how far back eight miles holy [ __ ] all
right
are you you're there does anybody else
so for me what strikes me about the
airport is always so weird and can i
know you fly a lot um is that
people forget it seems like people
forget they're in public
do you know what i mean like they
they for i don't know if they have their
headphones on so they think well nobody
can see me you know
but so i'm in the airport
and at the airport is where i like to
look for weird things
because the airport is where i see a lot
of weird [ __ ] guys a lot a lot a lot and
so i'm sitting there and um
what strikes what catches my eye first
is this gentleman
uh probably mid 60s
he's reading a book like this
why that gets me right away is because
this is how my dad reads a book
okay and i'm gonna tell you something
about my dad my dad is and for those of
you who know what i'm talking about my
dad is from a generation of guys
who are just gentlemen
just [ __ ] gentlemen and anything that
i associate with my dad i associate with
class and being a gentleman and
my dad still dresses up to go to the
airport
yeah man i hear you i mean that's it
right i show up
high in sweatpants you know what i mean
my dad's a classy dude he's a gentleman
man and so and also he still reads books
he doesn't like to read kindle he
doesn't read he wants to read a book he
likes the texture he likes the tan the
textile stuff and so he's holding it
like this
and i and the dudes dressed nice and i'm
like look at this gentleman
we should have more guys like this
hanging out at the airport and i just
start to scan the air nothing nothing
nothing let me check check back in with
my gentlemen
i checked back in and now this dude
[Music]
is doing this
reading like this still like this with
this hand
with this hand at this point the hand is
right here moving very slowly this
slowly
back like this
and i'm like
what is happening yeah i had that exact
look on my face to
right like what right
he goes like this and he lifts up a
little bit and he sneaks his hand under
and i'm like oh
he's gonna do a little little digging
you know
and i'm here for a dig i'll watch you
know uh
i look i i know i know i know i know and
i'll tell you why i'll tell you why you
judgey i'll tell you what
i don't like to see the dig itself if
i'm if i need to explain myself i will i
don't really need i don't i don't care
about the dig truthfully
i just want to see what you do with your
hand afterwards that's it
i want to know if i need to call the
health board if i need to wash something
i need to know where this dirty [ __ ] is
going right
so i'll take a look this dude digs and
i'm going to tell when i tell you he he
was there for longer than he should be
he was
and i'm watching him the whole way no
expression change on his face no nothing
and
he comes out guys
he comes out with his hand like this
now guys he went in like this out like
this
that means he's got
yeah he's got a plan
i believe the police would call this
intent
he
comes out like this
and then goes just like this
and i'm watching him like oh no no no no
no no
by the way does anyone want to guess
anyone guess what he did
sniffs okay anyone else want to guess
turn the page
you mean instead of this he went to this
he didn't do that but the next time i
tell the story he will i'll tell you
that right now
that's funny as [ __ ] man
yeah he's like i need a [ __ ]
rip
yeah oh boy he goes
and by the way the first thing i think
is as he's getting closer i'm like
am i about to watch
the very first ever self-inflicted dirty
sanchez in the history
you don't dirty sanchez yourself
i'm like what is going on i'm i'm just
i can't
figure out where he's moving so [ __ ]
slowly
i'm like is he torturing me on purpose
just this
and my man he just goes he goes just i
guess he goes
[Laughter]
like if chapstick had a butt butter
so i right when i see it i think to
myself
who else saw this
because this is the kind of person i am
guys i'm an arms wide open guy
if we're laughing i want us to laugh
together if i see something weird i want
us to enjoy this together
it's just who i am right so i'm looking
through the airport like i can't be the
only person who saw this i can't nobody
nothing nobody nothing nobody nothing
until sitting right across from me
there was a woman
eating her salad
like this
and i just screamed over to where i go
hey hey
right
and she just threw her fork in her bowl
and she across the airport she screams
[ __ ] yuck
i was like yeah you're not wrong
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]